hey everybody it's Mike from motor flows
and welcome to today's video today is uh
Monday January 9th 2023
it's the Monday after uh the non-farm
payrolls which is usually a great day
for trading because you're going to
often have a lot of movement one way or
the other today we got it in both
directions and the reason for that you
know because you know people have the
whole weekend to digest what came out on
Friday so if you remember Friday right
we had that nice uh Trend up most of the
day after the number came out right we
closed higher and then when we reopened
Sunday night you know we opened
um you know and started making new highs
right we took out Friday's high and then
um where am I here okay so then you know
Europe opened and we came down we
started making new lows you know we went
from 39 31 all the way down to 16 and a
half but then when the US came out it
was just Off to the Races right a big uh
nice move higher all the way up to 73
and a quarter okay and then what happens
eventually we start selling off down to
new lows you know I saw an interesting
uh tweet you know someone said what
chart pattern is this well someone wrote
knees uh Head Shoulders Knees and Toes
because it just kept going down I
thought that I got a kick out of that
honestly I don't know who tweeted that
whatever did kudos to you that gave me a
chuckle but looking at the order flow
you know it's quite interesting let's uh
let's dig a little bit into it now
last week I made a video about
recognizing a trend day early okay and
you know again you know sort of even
though we had this beautiful sell-off
from 73 and a quarter all the way down
to you know down to 09 and three
quarters this move up was also very nice
it's a very easy move to
um in my opinion to to catch early and
again sort of to recap what I talked
about last week recognizing when a
market is flow driven is looking for
those divergences within a relatively
short period of time the order flow
divergences that are being
um
failing basically being taken out right
and today was was no different okay we
saw a nice
um
flow driven Market basically
we had our first Divergence right here
3954 a second one 39 56 and a quarter
again what's an order flow Divergence
it's a new or equal high in this case
it's for selling Divergence it's a new
equal high with negative Delta and the
bar closing down right I know some
people they just want to trade every
Divergence but you can't right you got
to take it in context of the market just
because you have a Divergence doesn't
mean you automatically get short right
you want to put it in context with
what's happening in the markets okay so
got a Divergence got another Divergence
if you sold this one okay you just came
right back up next bar this one you know
people will argue well it did come off a
little bit okay fair enough but
eventually it came right back up so the
first one's at 902 second one at 905.
and then we get another one here at 9 35
so it's within about a half hour again I
like to give it you know about an hour
or so again it does it it's not
it's not written in sand you know if I
was looking at just 30 minutes you know
this is at 902 and this one's at 9 35
that'd be out of the parameters you know
when you're coding stuff you got to be
exact right if I told a programmer okay
you gotta code this for me and and they
can
um but at a given time parameter if I
gave them 30 minutes this wouldn't show
up and this is what being a Trader is
knowing when to extend it out one or two
minutes okay so
902 905 9
UM 935 okay you just get ready in here
okay because okay I got one Divergence
that failed two Divergence now you're
sitting on your third one you just drop
your buy stop right in here right above
this high if it comes back it came back
immediately sometimes you can get a
little bit of a pullback you know from
this high at 59 and a half you know
maybe trade down to 55 sort of circle
around but this one it just came
immediately right back up took it out
and immediately made new highs got all
the way up to 63 and a half and again
you know you have a buy stop seven and
59 and three quarters you know maybe you
get filled at at your price or you know
actually if your buy stops at nine and
three quarters probably gonna get filled
at sixty
um or even 60 and a quarter but in this
case probably fill that 60 because
there's some good liquidity there when
you're making new highs unless a stop
gets triggered there's tends to be
resting liquidity and coming up here I
can see the volumes you know you can see
1200 here 890 here 877 even here you
know when you're sort of going sideways
a bit 900
um so obviously you know you could have
got it filled maybe 60 60 and a quarter
worst case scenario filled at 60 and a
half how much heat do you take on this
trade this time well
it did pull back off this high at three
and a half
pull back to 58 and a half so maybe you
got filled here at the high of this bar
at 60 and a half
two points
60 and a half should be your entry you
know just move this line up here just so
you have a good idea
um and it keeps going up new high 68 and
a half pulls back doesn't quite even get
to your entry price
keeps going making new highs you get
failed Divergence failed Divergence
failed Divergence another failed
Divergence now this high up here 73 and
a quarter is the high of the day
so even if you're buying it at 60 and a
half
you know you got 10 points out of it
which is good
um you know if you're trying to hit a
home run and get 20 points or more out
of it okay fine you know because we
don't know yet that this is going to
happen right it's just going to sort of
fall off the cliff so what are some of
the signs and the weakness here at that
high well let's take a look here okay so
we hit our high 79 39 73 and a quarter
okay we do have a Divergence there I'm
not going to talk about ratios yet I'll
get that later this week
um you know I still want to get
everybody up to speed on things that I'm
looking for before I really dive into
you know more
specialized readings of order flow okay
so 10 15 high or so 10 17 rather in the
morning 39.73 and a quarter
pulls back
and then
it starts making its way back up towards
the high here and we get up to 72 and
three quarters this is around 10 26 27
k
doesn't quite reach there pulls back a
bit comes back down again you know we're
in a trend day
at this point
we made a high we made another attempt
at the high we're pulling back you know
I'm you know it's hard to say oh yeah
the move this is over right at this
point
um even though you obviously you got a
lot of negative Delta but we just had a
big move up remember that you know yeah
keep that in mind
um you know because we we moved from you
know we're Cash open right remember
where cash opened
um you know we're trading you know in
the 40s even got down into the 30s you
know during that first 10 minutes of the
cash basically between you know 30 and
you know I'll call it 40. okay this
whole time in there so you know we're
Trading
30 40 points higher okay so that's
already quite a move but I'm not yet
convinced that you know the selling is
aggressive selling coming in to drive
the market lower okay that we're seeing
up here rather
um at in this area up here in the 70s
because you do have the negative Delta
but again you had a nice move so people
are probably taking profits
um you know you don't really see people
jumping into the market adding on to
their positions here
um what I thought was
very interesting is when you got sort of
to around 11 30 this
third attempt at the high here right we
got all the way up to 72 and three
quarters now let's just draw this line
here I'll write one tick here
Okay so
what do we got here
so the first times you're trading up
here right you got your Divergence you
come off you know you're trading some
volume up there at 72 and three quarters
you come off and then you make this
final attempt up here and you just trade
two lots
right
that's not a good sign
okay it's like you know this Market is
kind of struggling to
to really make its move back up I mean
there was some interesting volume here
right some heavier volume trading at 71
and three quarters and 71 and a half
obviously you got this big buying
imbalance going up then you know there's
a thousand on the offer here then it's
bid here for 700 I mean trade 700 on the
bid 681 on the bid even the next buyer
people are still you know trying to
support this Market but it just gets
whacked right back down and
again it's sort of the The Telltale sign
is this two lots right we're now it's a
green candle so it doesn't qualify as as
an exhaustion print however you know I I
do have to respect that only two lots
traded there this was at the same level
that we had traded earlier again not a
lot of volume even here 10 21 28 so you
know about 60 contracts more or less
um we came back up two contracts this
time and this is on the back of an area
where there was some strong volume okay
the 72 down to
there's you know well it's called 71 and
three quarters 71 and a half 71 and a
quarter
um you know several thousand contracts
here we finally get past this volume
and it can't really trade much higher
right now you know one of the old noft
signals you know sorry you got your
sequential decline here to 147 188 256
um you know which is bearish as well but
the fact that we're making another run
up at that high and it just dies out
with two contracts is is not a good sign
and then the market starts
um you know basically pulls back down to
around the 65-ish area down in here
where it had been Trading
a little bit earlier
um
there was some interesting volume that
went through here around 11
45. that's where things got a little bit
interesting you can see here let's move
this line here okay
so basically right it just sort of close
out that trade so if you're along from
all those failed divergences right at 60
and a
um right here at 60 and a half okay the
fact that it's just sort of hanging
around up here can't go any higher you
have the high make one attempt made
another attempt and it's just going
sideways that's your opportunity to
close it out don't let it come back down
to break even but you know you're
spending a lot of time up around 69
because we hit that high at 10 actually
10 17. you know 10 27 we made another
run at it 10 55 made another run at it
they don't expect that all of a sudden
build up ahead of steam and keep going
out we could could very easily but
chances are it's not okay and you
already had two attempts to go up make
new highs after that high was made so if
it hasn't done it already it's probably
not then you saw some nice aggressive
buying coming in here right with a nice
stacked buying and balance there
that's your opportunity just ask screw
it get out you know I'm sure there's
other traders that were already long
also thinking the same thing you see a
lot of aggressive selling coming in here
after this High fails or this attempt at
the high fails are you seeing foreign
imbalances to here two here one one one
three
um so you've seen a lot of selling take
place there now what was interesting was
here this 3957 area okay so we came down
started coming down and all of a sudden
there's heavy volume coming in right
this isn't it at and off at a level
we've just been trading that right we
came down in here now you got big offer
here you can see the
um you know the 415 the 500 the 732 the
1200 obviously the 800 that's around
three and a half thousand contracts
um
going there and it's kind of holding
right it's acting as resistance on the
market every time the market sort of
comes back up it comes off again right I
mean you know those little guys that
trade with the
the Dome and the heat Maps they see that
size in there they're all excited you
know they got their dick in their hand
and they're like oh I gotta sell it okay
well it sells off you know they're
jumping in front at six and three
quarters it sells off down to what four
and a half you know it's not a big move
down
the final we get past it
okay so you had a big offer in there
that was acting as resistance
and all of a sudden it's failed so what
do you think is going to happen right
that resistance has been removed from
the market you look for the market to
pop back up and it does pops back up
from again that was at 7 57 gets all the
way back up to 60 it sort of hangs
around there you would look for it to be
some sort of support it did come down
you know to it 57 bounce back up to 59
and a half before it broke through again
and then it sort of just I don't want to
say it rotated around here but you know
it just sort of was rotating back and
forth at this point
um
when we got up to around one o'clock
okay when we're still trading
um
you know around the 4647 area I mean we
had come down to 36 then you know we
would get back up here right around one
o'clock okay on the bar chart
it's uh this area right in here right we
had again we sold off
got down to the the mid 30s then back up
to 45.
other than the rug got pulled out you
can see the big down candle what was
interesting and again this is
where using a footprint chart is going
to really make a big difference in in
your trading all you got to do is just
look for this thing it's an exhaustion
print here one contract
it's a red candle what you're looking at
is the volume on the top offer side
that's why it's highlighted in red
because that's bearish
and it's coming right it's what happened
Market sold off
rallied basically about 10 points over
10 points I mean 34 and a quarter all
the way up to
um you know 46 and three quarters trades
14 then trades one you know so yeah
we're getting less volume but this one
just sticks out like a sore thumb
and again you know other softwares have
copied my
exhaustion print concept right which is
just basically it's no algo or anything
like that it's just highlighting
something unique in the order flow it's
telling you on this red candle
that one contract traded right you got
one here now you got a bullish one here
it's green it's green but put it in
context where is it happening it's
happening
at a swing High
after uh you know over a 12 point move
basically
all right so you're looking for the
market to show some signs of weakness
and you see it now what's the difference
between this one and this one I mean you
could say this is a swing High I guess I
mean 34 and a quarter up to
41 and a quarter I mean that's you know
that that's not as really a big swing
high but you know it's it's a it's a
lower high obviously
um this one is just more optically
better but if you're watching things
like the delta right that's why I talk
about putting the pieces of water flow
together
here you got you know it's a smaller
move obviously it's about six points
five point six points but it's just
minus 24 Delta
here it's minus 460. so the selling is
is much stronger obviously the volume is
stronger 28.40 in the bar versus you
know 1922 so almost uh you know 900
contracts more volume in this candle
but it's just more
stronger in my opinion right because the
volume is stronger the Delta is stronger
but you know even if this was like this
next part minus 290 that's also nice you
know if this bar had you know a nice
strong Delta of minus 240 you know 10
times that amount yeah I'd be
excited a lot more but seeing that Delta
of just minus 24 is not much but here
after 4 13 Point move
you got that exhaustion print of one
contract
and then a strong negative Delta yeah
look for it to drop and it immediately
dropped from 44 down to just about 34
got down to 34 and a quarter so you know
almost 10 ticks 10 points rather not
ticks points in two minutes three
minutes okay but it never even got back
up to that exhaustion Prince
right that what was that at 46 and a
half that was it
all right then the move just you know at
this point it was just like uh a rock
rolling downhill just keep going on and
on lower and lower
okay
I mean and what was more interesting
about this move down
is
you're just seeing I mean these bids are
just getting taken out with impunity you
know I mean you've seen all those that
aggressive selling in there
you know with the just with by looking
at the imbalances right and you can see
Supply coming in as well but even you're
not you know you got negative Deltas
okay and even when you have the positive
Deltas they're not very strong 29 75 58
it's where's your aggressive buying it's
really absent here on this move down
okay so you know Watch What Happens
with the volume now again there's one
other
time and let's just go back to that that
105 time again because that was also
interesting this is more of a nuanced
look at what's going on in the volume
now like I said you know this volume in
this bar 2840 was much better than this
red candle here at 1922 the volume 1922
where you have the exhaustion print but
what was
what I found more interesting was you
had some nice buying going on here nice
volume six thousand two hundred fifty
one six thousand one eighty four then at
the High 3 900 that's nice that's that's
what you like to see on a move right
whether it's higher or lower you want to
see heavier
excuse me heavier volume than normal
right and you're seeing you know it's
much more than these previous bars this
is 1700 2800 3900 1700 so it's just like
you know people like woke up hey when I
say woke up it's one o'clock you know
people really get busy at that time
um so you got buyers coming into the
market heavy volume nice positive Delta
11.25 next bar very similar six thousand
volume then
3 900 not bad it's good you know it's
almost you know it's very strong it's
not six thousand but it's still strong
3900 is sort of one of your stronger
numbers in recent memory I I'm not going
to say oh you gotta take the average of
the last 20 bars and do that now you
just simple eye check how is it compared
to where we were earlier but then it
starts dropping off here right 2800 so
it's gone from strong strong
medium strong to
kind of average
but now the selling is coming in
so you could almost see that what was
making these bars strong was that
aggressive buying right obviously you're
getting any Italian buying imbalances
and
the volumes more volume being traded on
the offer but it's like
six thousand six thousand four thousand
twenty eight hundred
but this one is dominated by selling
okay so imagine if you still had some
yeah just call it I don't know 2 000
more contracts or a thousand more
contracts that was on
the aggressive buying side you know
you'd be looking at again you know 3 800
contracts and you know this bar might be
trading higher but it's not there it's
like that buying is is removed that's
why I talk about this is more of a
nuanced analysis there you're sort of
speculating I hate to say speculating
but you're sort of if you see it enough
you you understand what's happening is
is that buying pressure has been removed
it's strong strong
mildly strong now it's gone
right and that's why in my opinion it's
one of the reasons why that volume
dropped off but
um yeah I mean that moved down you know
it was a beautiful move down but really
there were signs in here that the market
was showing weakness there was a great
buying opportunity like I said at 60
and a half you know all the way
you know a nice 10 point move could have
been had but the fact that we're
struggling at these Highs at the high of
the day coming back and coming back
again lack of volume and then when the
market starts moving down
again you see every time it starts
poking back up you're seeing lack of
volume
so you know understand like when you
have lack of volumes a sign of
exhaustion right everyone thinks order
flow is like looking at the the book map
or the depth of market and looking for
big areas of volume well yeah that's
just one part of it you also got to look
at the areas where there's lack of
volume lack of interest in the market
because that is also an area for
opportunity
so again you know I hope you guys
enjoyed this video
if you haven't already be sure to
subscribe to the channel I've I've been
trying to get a video out every day for
you guys so we're talking about
different things on order flow so you
know if you really want to improve your
order flow analysis again you know what
I talk about a lot of things in these
videos and it's not about oh my gosh
there's so much I got to learn no it's
about taking the pieces of the order
flow
finding what makes sense to you and
applying it to your own trading to help
you become a better Trader so thanks
everyone have a great day bye bye